Road Trip Siri want to go to the beach
starting roots Rockaway Beach no this is
not my car and no I don't think you care
at all about my road trip but I've been
driving this insane 2016 Corvette
Stingray to test apple's carplay with it
you plug in your phone and control all
sorts of things like calls music maps
and other stuff with your voice or via
the screen text jonathan Krim she's my
boss okay what do you want to say to
jonathan creme I'm not feeling too well
today not gonna make it in I'm gonna
rest up your message to Jonathan Prince
says I'm not feeling too well today I'm
not gonna make it and I'm going to rest
up ready to send it yes sirree I do want
to send that and in fact I'm very
impressed with your transcription skills
that is until I roll down the windows or
put the top down Siri can tell me a hair
appointment safety experts say talking
to Siri can be a distraction but it's
not as bad as this touchscreen which
feels worse than one on an airplane seat
I do like that car play works with
Spotify and other music apps but Siri
can only DJ app with music Siri play
little red Corvette Siri I'm starving
where's the closest Mickey D's what kind
of businesses are you looking for no
sirree McDonald's where is the closest
McDonald's getting directions to
McDonald's
the destination is on your left you know
Syria I'm still not sure that was the
closest McDonald's Apple Maps has gotten
way better and I haven't crashed into
the Atlantic Ocean just yet the traffic
data is still really weak and so is
points of interest
speaking of traffic Google Maps and ways
would not have sent me this way the car
I do wish Siri knew more about where I
was going next and I wish Apple Maps
we're as good as Google Maps but
actually this is the best way to drive
around if you've got an iPhone okay but
I asked about the car the car is
absolutely amazing the destination is on
your left
Siri are you there